let's bring in El jaer senior political
analyst maam Bashar thank you once again
for joining us we've seen Iran cropping
up on more and more front almost uh
every single day what is driving their
involvement and I mean do you see this
continuing you know sometimes the most
obvious answer is the right answer and
for me it's obvious uh that Iran wants
to send two messages one towards the
inside and once towards the outside
world and it's basically the same
message saying that you cannot mess with
Iran that the recent attacks against
Iranians whether Iranian citizens or
Iranian leaders is not acceptable to
Iran Iran is a country that is a
original Power you cannot mess with it
and hence Iran will take measures even
if these measures might be quite risky
such as angering uh two important
neighbors like Iraq and Pakistan now
bombing in Syria unfortunately Syria has
been violated so many times one can one
actually lost count of it but to violate
the national sovereignty of both Iraq
and Pakistan within the week uh might
send the message that Iran is serious
about its business but it's still quite
risky in the sense of angering two
important neighbors while it's at the
same time trying to confront the
presence of the United States in the
region yeah so that message what is it
exactly and and how do you think it's
going to be received in Iraq and
Pakistan in particular you know the fact
that uh so many Iranians have been hit
uh over the past few weeks and
months in the end of the day
undermines uh the
authority uh and the influence of the
Iranian regime within the country
country and in the Middle East so the
message is we are strong we are
conscious of what is happening and we
are more than capable of responding and
this is might not be preemptive but this
is certainly a punishment to those who
are attacking Iran or to those who
are um hospitable to those who are
attacking Iran and hence they are
attacking very particular
targets as in aril or as in bistan but
at the same time they are violating uh
their neighbors uh National sovereignty
and hence the message is whether you are
a group or whether you are a country
hosting that group we are more than
willing to act this might not bod well
for us and for our future relationships
but certainly we're going to send a
message of confidence to our people that
we are conscious and we are more than
willing to act and that we are a
original Power and you cannot mess with
Iran so what happens next are we going
to continue to see this escalate further
do you think I think it depends on what
happens in the region it depends of
attack uh is are carried against Iran or
Iranian leaders uh but clearly uh this
could be uh a trend meaning this was not
a one time off right it wasn't just
hitting Syria or just hitting Iraq or
Pakistan the fact that they happened all
three attacks within a short period of
time is a message that this might be the
way forward that just Iran is not going
to take it laying down anymore that
whatever happens uh in Iran or against
Iranian uh military or civilian targets
will be met uh with Force even if that
Force might put Iran in a bind with its
neighbors okay thank you so much M as
always we really do appreciate it thank
you